Todd asks I noticed that you posts of
themed things multiple times please
explain why this is a calculated move
and not obnoxious Todd everything I do
is calculated and so the answer is yes
it's calculated and the reason I'm
posting multiple times a day and I think
you're referring to clearly Twitter is
the before-mentioned answer in the
Instagram question come on questions ago
which is Twitter has gotten noisy I've
looked at data and intuition looked
inside myself and decided that it's okay
for me to do it multiple times because
the speed is happening the hardcore fans
will accept that it's okay I've seen
that and just so many call it 90% of
people that want to consume I kept me
still some things that I'm on in the
nineteen time on like the Twitter
mistake on the deck you know I put out
today and people I go and like it's you
know there's just so much noise that I
feel the market has changed and I think
it's appropriate almost like a scrolling
bar at the bottom of ESPN right if you
think about that that's looping the same
stuff and it doesn't bother me I can
choose to look at the bottom or not and
weirdly and I'm sure all of you do this
sometimes you just look again and again
and again it's kind of wild that way I
think that Twitter's fire hose now
replicates the bottom ticker of CNBC and
ESPN and I think it's the right
execution to put out your stuff at
different times different time zones I
want to hit my European and Asian and
non-us family what's up not us I want to
hit my West Coast peeps you know you got
to play it differently and that's just
the way it is and I think it's
appropriate in a December 16 2014 world
to put out the same content multiple
times on the Twitter I like calling it
on the Twitter in a world where in
December 16th
you know 2008 I felt differently I
changed my mind
consistently which is why which is why I
think I win and honestly which is why I
think I'm worth the attention that
you're applying to this show and why I
think this format works because the game
is changing quickly and
and if you're not adjusting you're gonna
lose that you know the 85 Bears won on a
system that doesn't work in phase NFL
hack pack the you know mm who won last
year the Seahawks the Seahawks aren't
even able to execute the same game plan
as last year in the NFL because of the
way the officials call pass interference
and things of that nature and so you
just gotta keep evolving and if you
don't you lose and that's the evolution
of my game so advice that I gave him jab
jab jab right hook would it look
differently today about Twitter because
between time I wrote it and this minute
the game has changed
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe